كبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان لواء
دوريرد اضرار طفيفه ولا اصابات همم ولكن
يبقى هذا الهجوم يحمل دلالات ورسائل كبيره
برايك ما هي وضمن اي صراع يدخل
اتركك داخل الصراع الثنائي يعني اجتمعت
الى الحديث عن كاس العالم لاقارب الساعه
لن تعود الى الوراء كاس العالم يسير
التحضيرات كامله انا هنا لاود ان امجد او
امدح ولكن كمحلل في البعدين السياسي
والعسكري اقول عقارب الساعه لن تعود هذه
الاحداث ثنائيه لن تؤثر على الحضور ولا
على النشاطات والامور المركب يسير قدما
هكذا ارى وهكذا اقرا وهكذا ما اتمنى ان
يحدث الان هذا صراع سواء اطلق عليه في
الظل او صراع غير مباشر انا اقول هناك
صراع غير مباشر وليس في الظل هو صراع في
العالم صراع مكشوف تاريخيا اسرائيل اعتمدت
ما قيل سياسه الغموض النووي وقالوا لن
نكون اول لن نكون
من يدخل السلاح ولن نسمح ولن نكون الثاني
ولن نسمع للاخر
وتركوا الباب مفتوح علما ان لديها 200 راس
نوويه الان اسرائيل تبنت بعض العمليه همم
لخدمه اغراض انتخابيه اشارت المراسله وقال
وتحدثت واتهامات التي وجدت الى نتنياهو
نتنياهو قدم عرضا على الشاشه كيف تم
الحصول على وثائق
بالالاف من داخل ايران من خلال عملاء
الموساد هو كان يقدم همم لخدمه مشروع
الانتخابي للوصول وبالتالي تم توجيه اليوم
والانتهامات اسرائيل تبقي على الغموض
وتبقي على انهاء الجمل ذات النهايه
المفتوحه ولكنها هي في صراع مباشر مع
ايران مع الازرق على الايراني لان
اسرائيل منذ 2011 وضعت عده خطوط حمراء
تتعلق بالواقع السوري
والنفوذ الايراني سواء في سوريا او في
الضاحيه والجنوب اللبناني ومن اهمها عدم
وصول اسلحه الدمار شامل عدم وصول صواريخ
بالستيه عدم وصول صواريخ بحر وبالاخير
كاصبح خط جديد عدم وصول قطع غيار لتطوير
الصواريخ المملوكه
بيدي حزب الله ومصانعها موجوده في منطقه
سافيتا وفي وادي جهنم في في في سوريا اذا
هناك خطوط حمراء واسرائيل تمارس اعتداءات
على الجغرافيا السوريه كلما تحسنت على
معلومات
والشواهد كثيره جدا
هو صراع ثنائي
اريد ان اعود الى التفاصيل الحادثه لواء
فايز الدويري في في سؤال متعلق بالاخبار
التي اوردتها القناه الثانيه عشر
الاسرائيليه طبعا في تواصلها مع ملاك او
الشركه عفوا الشركه المشغله لهذه الناقله
حينما تتحدث الشركه ان الاستهداف تم
بصاروخ وليس بطائره مسيره وان اثر هذا
الصاروخ لم يحدث اضرارا كبيرا على متن همم
السفينه يعني ما مدى يعني دقه واقعيه همم
هذا هذا التصريح من همم من القناه الثانيه
الاسرائيليه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه يعني
انا اعتبره تصريح كانت تطلع معلومات
اعلاميه لا استطيع ان اتمنى حتى اللحظه
الحاليه لماذا لانه يحتاج الامر الى كشف
منخبراء متخصصين في علم المقذوفات وللاسف
اتحدث بها انا احد الاشخاص المختصين في
هذا المجال واقول الان مكان الاصابه
جهه الاصابه زاويه تحدد زاويه الاقتراب
اذا كانت الاصابه في الجهه البعيده من
السفينه لا يمكن ان يكون صاروه اذا كان
بزاويه من الحاده لا يمكن ان يكون من
صاروخ وبالتالي هناك اجراءات يقوم بها
الخبراء المختصين انا لن انسى ولن اتبنى
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه رغم التصريح الذي
صدرها عن الجانب الاسرائيلي بالاتصال انا
عميل الى طائره مسيره اكثر مما اميل الى
صاروخ علما انني ان يكون
لكن الصاروخ
زوايا سقوط الصاروخ معروفه طريقه الاثار
التي يتركها وطبيعه الفجوه التي تحدث
مختلفه لان طبيعه المطلوب مختلفه كميه
المختار المتفجرات مختلفه سرعه المقذوف
مختلفه عن الكمازي اذا هناك امور فنيه
يعني قائد هذه يهتم بهذا الشان والاختصاص
لكن بغض النظر سواء كان صاروخ او طائره
المهم المصدر الذي انطلق منه صاروخ او
الطائره كما قلت في بدايه حديثي ان ايران
هي خلفيه المشهد سواء كانت هي التي نفذت
او احد اذرعها اشكرك جزيل الشكر اللواء
فايز الدويري خبير العسكري والاستراتي